dada la integral definida que va de 1 a
4 de fx de x 6 y la integral definida
que va de 1 a 7 de fx de x igual a 11
queremos saber cuál es la integral
definida que va de 4 a 7 de fx de x
bueno en mi cabeza estoy visualizando
estas áreas bajo la curva que se generan
entre igual a fx y el eje x así que
vamos a dibujarlo no sabemos exactamente
que sea fx pero podemos dibujar una
función arbitraria solo para visualizar
las cosas entonces vamos a dibujar el
eje y este es nuestro eje x vamos a ver
en este caso todo sucede de 1 a 7
entonces vamos a poner 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y
podemos poner 8 si quiere entonces
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 y ahora vamos
a dibujar la función de igual a fx
dibujaré algo arbitrariamente supongamos
que la gráfica se ve así esto es que
igual a efe
y recuerden que este es nuestro eje x y
este es el eje y ok y ahora pensemos en
qué es lo que representa cada una de
estas integrales bueno la integral
definida que va de 1 a 4 nos dice que
vamos de 1 a 4 entonces esta área
corresponde a la integral definida que
va de 1 a 4 esta es el área bajo la
curva que se genera entre la función ye
igual a fx y el eje i es igual a 6 y
también tenemos la región que va de 4 a
7 y esta área bajo la curva representa a
la integral definida que queremos
resolver que es la integral que va de 4
a 7 de fx de x esto es lo que queremos
conocer entonces esta es el área bajo la
curva de la región que hay entre x igual
a 4 y x igual a 7 entre igual a fx y el
eje x y bueno también nos da en esta
información
en que la integral definida que va de 1
a 7 que va de 1 hasta 7 miren es la suma
de las dos regiones así que podemos
reescribir esto como la integral
definida que va de 1 a 4 de fx de x más
la integral definida que va de 4 a 7 de
fx de x y esto es igual a la integral
definida que va de 1 a 7 de fx de x y
observen lo que sucede aquí la primera
integral corresponde al área que va de 1
a 4 y después pasamos de 4 a 7 y la suma
de esas dos áreas nos da el área que va
de 1 a 7
entonces como nos han dado mucha
información ya sabemos que esto es igual
a 6 y que esto es igual a 11 entonces
tenemos que 6 más esto es igual a 11 por
lo tanto la integral definida que va de
a 7 debe de ser igual a 5
5 otra forma de verlo sería que si esta
región es igual a 6 tiene un área de 6 y
toda el área es igual a 11 esto más esto
es igual a 11 entonces lo que no
conocemos es decir el área anaranjada es
igual a 11 menos 6 por lo tanto esta
área es igual a 5